I mean the situation that Julian is
absolutely extraordinary I have never
witnessed anything like it before the
amount of ordinance that is being used
um is really just mind-blowing a bomb
after bomb sailing through the sky and
exploding on the skyline and it's like
that along that front now in back move
itself we think there are still
civilians stuck inside the city a living
Subterranean lives undergrounds further
along the front line in chess if you are
there definitely are people living there
the most people have gone and what they
are facing on a daily basis is really a
matter of life and death you don't know
because your your town your village your
city is in artillery range what is going
to come in next for instance we were
driving through chass if you are we
turned the corner we traveled down a
road about a minute before we did that
we heard the sound of a loud explosion
and as we turn that corner we saw a ball
of fire exploding a vehicle had been
been hit it is extremely random it's
extremely indiscriminate and you don't
know what's coming next now of course
all eyes will be focusing really on uh
the counter-offensive which is coming we
expect very soon it could be this month
it could be next month it could be in
the next few days we don't know it is a
closely guarded secret but the fighting
there is already extremely ferocious and
it's expected it's going to become even
more intense